[Musik]
bleib aus kall der presseclub mit jörg
schöne worden
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntagmittag die
politischen erschütterungen waren seit
tagen zu spüren aber das beben heute
morgen um 10 uhr hat wohl niemand
erwartet andrea nahles die noch spd
partei und fraktionsvorsitzende zieht
sich komplett aus der politik zurück
würde auch ihr bundestagsmandat abgeben
das ganze ist eine reaktion auf die
wahlen vom vergangenen sonntag die waren
historisch union und spd sagten erneut
auf tiefstände abschnitten so schlecht
ab wie noch nie in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik man muss sich das mal
vorstellen die beiden sind mittlerweile
so schwach dass sie nicht einmal mehr
die hälfte der wählerschaft hinter sich
haben
die lange zeit so genannte große
koalition ist deutlich geschrumpft und
noch eine teilung zeichnet sich in der
republik ab so deutlich wie nie die
teilung zwischen jung und alt die
jüngere hälfte der wählerschaft achtung
das sind die unter 60-jährigen die
jüngere hälfte der wählerschaft hat
erstmals die grünen zur stärksten partei
bestimmt auch das hat neben ausgelöst
unser presseclub heute tiefschläge und
einen rücktritt wie weit geht es mit
union und spd noch bergab und ich freue
mich auf diese gäste dagmar rosenfeld
des bei uns chefredakteurin die welt ich
begrüße herzlich katharina nocon freie
journalistin bloggerin sie schreibt
katasters welt herzlich willkommen
steffen lübke redakteurin politik
ressort von spiegel online und nico
fried ist bei uns der leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der süddeutschen
zeitung
es war eine erklärung per e-mail
vorbereitet von andrea nahles die heute
morgen um 10 uhr das licht der
öffentlichkeit erblickt und unter
anderem heißt es dort die diskussion in
der fraktion und die vielen
rückmeldungen aus der partei haben hier
gezeigt dass der zur ausübung meiner
ämter notwendigen rückhalt nicht mehr da
ist
am kommenden montag werde ich daher im
parteivorstand meinen rücktritt als
vorsitzende der spd und am dienstag in
der fraktion als vorsitzende der
bundestags fraktionen erklären frau
rosenfeld die erklärung endet mit dem
satz bleibt beieinander und handelt
besonnen hat andrea nahles besonnen
gehandelt
naja also zum ersten mal muss man sagen
dass wir jetzt gerade in diesen stunden
das ende einer spitzenpolitikerin
erleben das brutale ende einer
spitzenpolitikerin und auch den
unmenschlichen umgang einer partei
untereinander und offenbar ist
menschlichkeit leider keine kategorie
mehr politik und die große frage ist
jetzt ob es ohne andrea nahles für die
spd tatsächlich besser werden kann klar
ist auch mit andrea nahles wäre es wohl
nicht mehr gut geworden was da in den
vergangenen tagen in den
fraktionssitzungen und gremiensitzungen
gelaufen ist was man sich gegenseitig an
den kopf geschmissen hat an brutalitäten
das war nichts war nicht mehr zu heilen
und andrea nahles hat sich verzockt aber
auch ihre gegner haben sich verzockt wir
haben erlebt dass zwei strategien in der
spd beide nicht aufgegangen sind zwei
gegensätzliche da waren zum einen
diejenigen die nahles schon loswerden
wollten aber das gerne bis zum herbst
hinaus gezögert hätten um ihr die
ostdeutschen wahlen die absehbar für die
spd auch in einem desaster enden werden
noch mit ihr mit auf den weg geben zu
können da hat andrea nahles einen strich
durch die rechnung gemacht und sie hat
darauf gesetzt dass wenn sie die
machtfrage jetzt steht dass sie damit
die debatte beendet und auch noch die
nötige mehrheit bekommt wenn die partei
sich entscheiden muss dass sie sich dann
doch zu ihr bekennt beides ist nicht
aufgegangen und jetzt erleben wir die
selbstzerstörung einer partei druck und
was hat es bei ihnen ausgelöst
verständnis oder kopfschütteln heute
morgen beides würde ich sagen einerseits
würde ich nicht sagen dass es andrea
nahles allein gelegen hat dass der kurs
jetzt so ist wie er ist und dass die
umfragewerte auch abgestürzt sind was
ich interessant an der debatte fand war
dass die jusos also die
jugendorganisation der partei wenn man
sich das letzte jahr anschaut eigentlich
konsequent gegen den kurs der eigenen
partei auf die straße gegangen ist zum
einen bei der urheberrechtsreform aber
auch beides for future aber auch bei den
novellen der polizei gesetze in den
bundesländern das heißt wir haben hier
eine jugendorganisation von 50.000
menschen jungen menschen die in der
politik aktiv werden wollen die aus
meiner sicht nicht angemessen im
bundesvorstand repräsentiert wurden und
deren wünsche auf deren wünsche andrea
nahles auch nicht eingegangen
ich würde jetzt allerdings davor warnen
zu sagen mit einem personalwechsel ist
alles gut denn die jungen menschen
wünschen sich vor allem eine veränderung
in der politik und da würde ich
eigentlich sehr viele chancen bei der
spd sehen ja wenn wir jetzt den
klimawandel anschauen wenn wir eine co2
steuer bekommen
wer ist ja eigentlich aufgabe der
sozialdemokraten zu sagen wie lösen wir
das sozial gerecht dass es nicht darauf
hinausläuft dass die reichen dann weiter
fliegen und die ärmere menschen sich das
dann nicht mehr leisten herfried sie
leiten auch eine parlamentsredaktion in
berlin solche nachrichten hat man selten
was ist ihnen durch den kopf gegangen
heute morgen
ich war überrascht das gebe ich zu ich
war hatte schon damit gerechnet dass es
sehr schwer werden würde für frau nahles
dieses spiel was sie angestoßen hat
jetzt mit der machtfrage in der fraktion
zu gewinnen
ich glaube sie ist letztlich an 23
punkten gescheitert zum einen hat sie
ihr versprechen von parteitagen gewählt
wurde einfach nicht einlösen können
die partei parallel zur regierung zu
erneuern das ist nicht allein ihre
schuld aber sie steht natürlich in der
verantwortung
zum zweiten muss sie natürlich gerade
stehen für schlechte wahlergebnisse als
parteivorsitzende das ist auch klar aber
zum dritten ist es auch so dass sie eben
die symbolfigur schlechthin für diese
große koalition in der spd sie war
diejenige die auf dem sonderparteitag in
einer sehr weh menden leidenschaftlichen
rede die partei praktisch in die
verhandlungen gebrüllt hat möchte fast
sagen
und deswegen ist sie dafür die figur und
der frust in der kot in der spd über
diese große koalition ist so wahnsinnig
groß inzwischen offensichtlich dass man
es auch an ihr ausgelassen hat und ich
würde frau hosenfeld recht geben die art
und weise wie man es teilweise an ihre
ausgelassen hat ist wirklich fast
skandalös also heiko maas hat
offensichtlich in der fraktionssitzung
die frage aufgeworfen ob man mit einem
mann auch so umgegangen wäre ich glaube
es war vielleicht auch leichter eine
frau dermaßen ich finde benutzt jetzt
mal das wort anzupassen naja kurt beck
hat ähnliches erlebt
lüdke kurz dahinter als uns an die
tonregie ich bräuchte bitte den sender
ausgang
herr lüdke selbstzerstörung einer partei
hat frau rosenfeld gesagt was ist ihr
eindruck was ging ihnen durch den kopf
heute morgen ja tatsächlich also mich
hat auch der zeitpunkt überrascht
gleichwohl war es ja seit mittwoch
zumindest parteiinternen klar dass es
mittelfristig und andrea nahles keine
keine zukunft geben wird das nicht mehr
klappen wird mit ihr und der spd oder
zumindest mit ihr im fraktionsvorsitz
die frage ist nun wie es weitergeht und
tatsächlich glaube ich ist sie wirklich
diejenigen die für die groko gekämpft
hat deswegen ist ihre ihr rücktritt auch
eine niederlage für die groko
befürworter gleichwohl haben sich
natürlich so das linke lager um kühn hat
dass ich das eigentlich anders
vorgestellt einen anderen zeitplan
vorgehabt die wollten im september gar
nicht mal so sehr frau nahles stürzen
sondern vor allem die groko und jetzt
stehen sie da und ohne klare position zu
zum rücktritt von frau nahles und
offenbar auch ohne ohne echte führung
also es hat sich angedeutet matthias
miersch von den parteilinken hat
irgendwie geäußert er möchte nicht
kandidieren auch da sieht es ziemlich
kopflos aus haben wir ein problem in
einer partei oder haben wir ein problem
in einer bundesregierung einer koalition
die eigentlich niemand der beteiligten
wollte alle beteiligten hatten
eigentlich andere probleme im verlauf
des zustandekommens ist schon herr
schulz gestürzt
herr seehofer musste aufgeben frau
merkel hat den parteivorsitz aufgegeben
mit andrea nahles beginnt jetzt schon
die zweite rücktrittsgründe wie stabil
ist diese regierung noch mit der wir es
in berlin zu tun haben also diese
regierung ist von anfang an ein zwangs
gebilde gewesen
die spd hat dann sich entschieden aus
staats verantwortung was man ja auch
hoch anrechnen muss in diese koalition
reinzugehen und mit dem kopf hat die
partei das auch mitgetragen aber mit dem
herzen ist sie nie in dieser koalition
gewesen da sitzt der kühler kroko
stachel zu tief beide parteien auch
union also cdu und csu haben in der
ganzen legislaturperiode bisher eher
nicht die regierungsparteien sondern
eher wie selbst therapiegruppen gewirkt
weil sie wahnsinnig mit sich selbst
beschäftigt waren cdu und csu
so haben sich untereinander zerstritten
haben sich dann wieder versöhnt dann
haben beide parteien neue
parteivorsitzende besucht das mit
parteiinternen wahl kämpfen begleitet
die spd ist aus diesen aus diesem diese
aversion die man gespürt hat teil dieser
regierung sein zu müssen nicht
rausgekommen da waren die kühnheit und
stegners die ständig vom seitenrand
reingegrätscht haben und es für mich aus
meiner perspektive ist es an der zeit
dass diese große koalition kapituliert
und den weg frei macht für eine
regierung die sich wieder mit diesem
land und nicht mit sich selbst
beschäftigt teilt die runde dass also
ich würde auch sagen es fehlt einem
empfehlen einmal jährlich die argumente
noch für diese große große koalition
nicht nur weil auch das personal immer
weniger wird
aber es ist natürlich auch eine frage
was was eigentlich stattdessen natürlich
kann man jetzt sagen man macht
vorgezogene neuwahlen
aber so wie die situation im moment ist
ist ja nicht ganz klar welche
konstellationen dann dabei wieder
herauskommen würden das würde jetzt
einen wahlkampf geben der über den
ganzen sommer gehen würde weil die
wahlen eigentlich kaum früher als im
herbst frühestens stattfinden könnten
das ist jetzt auch nicht gerade das was
man sich für das land wünscht insofern
ist es schon eine sehr schwierige
situation vielleicht müssen jetzt in der
spd noch mal ein paar sich
zusammenreißen und die verantwortung
übernehmen die da auch schon sind jemand
wie olaf scholz der sich ja bisher auch
nicht wahnsinnig eingesetzt hat für die
erneuerung der spd sondern vor allem
seinen stiefel da als finanzminister
gemacht hat muss man sehen aber es ist
tatsächlich schwierig da jetzt einen
einfachen ausweg zu messen frohe kunde
dass wir das beste ich denke es ist
schwierig eine partei aus einer
situation heraus zu erneuern
der größere koalitionspartner einem mit
dem wissen dass man sehr zurückhaltend
was neuwahlen an anbelangt ist wirklich
viel rein drücken kann was man
eigentlich nicht möchte und das ist auch
gegenüber der parteibasis als die spd
vesper weil sie sich am schwersten
theater jetzt mit neuwaren also
langfristig wenn man die letzten jahre
betrachtet hätte es ganz viele exit
punkte gegeben an denen die spd hätte
sagen können das tragen wir nicht mit
wir steigen jetzt aus und weil aber die
umfragewerte im sinken begriffen waren
dann hat man eben so lange gezögert und
ich denke das war ein fehler man hätte
einfach viel früher die bremse ziehen
müssen ich bin da ganz bei kunert und
sagen müssen wir erneuern jetzt diese
partei und zwar aus einer position
heraus wo wir eben nicht an die union
gekettet sind und ich finde es auch und
bringen es gut dass jemand wie kunert
aufsteht und öffentlich seine eigene
partei kritisiert weil man muss ja auch
die innenwirkung sehen jemand wie künast
hält ganz viele spd-mitglieder in der
partei die sonst längst ausgetreten
werden also für die spd glaube ich auch
kette ein klarer bruch sehr gut also die
müssen sich nicht nur erneuern die
brauchen ein neues viel schärferes
profil und das in der groko das haben
wir jetzt gesehen ist tatsächlich
offensichtlich utopisch insofern ein
klarer bruch mit dieser großen koalition
drehte langfristig der spd sehr gut und
tatsächlich ist es ja aber auch so man
hatte sich das so vorgestellt man tritt
aus aus klaren inhaltlichen
gesichtspunkten irgendwann dann mal
eventuell nach der halbzeit der großen
koalition und ehrlicherweise sind wir
jetzt an einem punkt angelangt wo die
spd austritt weil sie sich selbst
zerfleischt weil sie schlechte
wahlergebnisse ein pferd das ist
natürlich nicht glaubwürdig die haben
also ein problem haben gleichwohl würde
ich sagen
raus aus der große klare vielleicht auch
einen klaren linksruck
so haben es tatsächlich andere
sozialdemokratische parteien vorgemacht
das kann dazu führen dass man nicht mehr
40 prozent wie unter lafontaine oder
schröder bekommt aber vielleicht so 24
oder so wenn man wieder ein klareres
profil hat angenommen ist wäre so
verhält hat die kanzlerin hat frau
merkel überhaupt noch das mandat dann zu
regieren
naja also sollte die spd es wird ja
jetzt einen vorgezogenen bundesparteitag
geben müssen auf dem der neue
parteivorstand gewählt werden wird
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
dieser bundesparteitag nicht zugleich
auch die große frage die im raum steht
diskutiert die ist
ohnehin halbzeitbilanz angesagt das wird
nicht mehr voneinander zu trennen sein
wenn man sich anguckt das bei dem
letzten sonderparteitag als es um den
eintritt in koalitionsverhandlungen ging
trotz aller leidenschaft von frau nahles
und trotz ihrer lauten stimme ist am
ende über 40 prozent waren die das nicht
wollen dann ist der punkt glaube ich mit
dem spd parteitag gekommen wo sich dann
auch die groko frage entscheiden wird
das irre an dieser ganzen geschichte ist
dass das desaster der spd am ende die
cdu und annegret kramp karrenbauer
stärken wird weil wenn die spd sich
entscheidet den schlussstrich zu ziehen
dann kommt der kakao aus der
verlegenheit heraus die machtfrage zu
stellen wann denn nun der übergang von
ihr zu merkel tatsächlich vollendet wird
das sind manchmal die seltsamen wege die
politik gehen kann
ich würde nur noch mal gerne etwas sagen
zu der rolle von kevin kühnert auch also
ich teile das ja absolut dass ein
jüngerer prominenter in der spd kritik
üben darauf und soll und die personen
die das am wenigsten zu kritisieren hat
ist andrea nahles die ja selber auf
diese art auch groß geworden ist und
agiert hat aber sie haben vorhin drei
punkte aufgezählt die den jusos nicht
gefallen haben den fürther haben sie gar
nicht genannt aber der gehört natürlich
dazu nämlich die große koalition an sich
jetzt ist es aber nun mal so dass es
nicht nur auf diesem parteitag eine
entscheidung für die verhandlung gegeben
hat sondern es hat eine
mitgliederbefragung gegeben die jedoch
immerhin eine zweidrittelmehrheit für
diese koalition ergeben hat ich glaube
auch grünert muss sich schon fragen
welche rolle er gespielt hat dass er
diese koalition trotzdem immer wieder in
frage gestellt hat kritisiert hat und
nun wird über die fehler in wahlkämpfen
und so viel gesprochen aber sie sagten
gerade dass er kinder die auch
sympathisanten der partei hält ich bin
nicht so ganz sicher ob er mit seiner
kollektivierung diskussion die hier
vielleicht nur halb absichtlich
angestoßen hat tatsächlich so viele
gehalten hat oder ob er nicht damit auch
ein paar verloren hat also ich finde das
ist so ein typischer punkt klar ist
andrea nahles nicht alleine schuld da
sind auch viele andere
in der prominenten spitze aber ich finde
kühnert hat da auch eine portion mit
hart wurden und man muss ihr ja auch
lassen und das waren die beiden das dass
man ja schon versucht hat inhaltlich
sich ein profil ein neueres zu geben
also die diese elende hartz-reform frage
die diese partei jahrelang gespalten hat
und über die man gehadert hat da hat es
ja nun entscheidung gegeben das hartz4
zu überwinden ist man hat sogar es
geschafft etwas aufzulegen was den namen
agenda trägt agenda 20 25 ich glaube das
dilemma da es gewesen dass nahles und
auch scholz führende köpfe bei der
befürwortung und durchsetzung der hartz
reformen waren und sehr lange daran
festgehalten haben und dass so ein
kurswechsel
ein abrupter schwer vermittelbar ist
wenn man die gesichter mit den reformen
wiederum in verbindung
sie haben das stichwort inhalte genannt
und ich habe am vergangenen sonntag im
wahlstudio eine grafik gezeigt
an deren zustandekommen ich noch vor
zwei jahren gar nicht geglaubt hätte
nämlich es zeigt sich wie
unterschiedlich politisch ausgerichtet
verschiedene generationen in der
bundesrepublik mittlerweile sind und ich
habe die grafik noch mal mitgebracht was
viele nicht wissen ist dass die eine
hälfte der wählerschaft man weiß dass
nie so ganz genau aber die eine hälfte
der wählerschaft ungefähr 160 vielleicht
auf unter 58 ist und für diesen teil
sieht man auf der linken seite das
ergebnis und für den älteren teil die
über 60 jährigen sieht man es auf der
rechten seite dort sagt man ist die welt
für die union noch in ordnung 41 prozent
und auch die spd ist immerhin noch über
20 bei den muss man ja faktisch sagen
rentnerinnen und rentnern aber auf der
linken seite sind eben nicht nur die
jungen die bei pride s&p-future auf die
straße gehen sondern da sind die
berufsanfänger der sind die
berufserfahrenen da sind eigentlich auch
die die führungs generation die wir
haben und da sind die grünen zum ersten
mal in der deutschen geschichte stärkste
partei doppelt so stark wie die spd
insofern haben wir es ja mit einer
entwicklung zu tun die wir seit jahren
beobachten das ist jetzt keine explosion
die plötzlich passiert ist sondern das
ist ein weg in vielen schritten
und deshalb sie haben das stichwort
inhalte genannt
franken was führt dann dazu dass die spd
sehr deutlich aber auch die union für
ihre verhältnisse relativ deutlich
abgemeldet ist bei den jungen und
mittelalten ja nach dem
jahrhundertsommer 2018 ist vielen
menschen einfach klar geworden dass das
klimathema nicht eins von vielen ist
sondern das ist 1 das entscheidende
thema dass darüber entscheiden wird wie
wir in zukunft in diesem land leben
werden ob wir gut leben werden ja und
von daher ist es klar dass eine partei
die die systeme nach vorne stellt auch
glaubwürdig nach vorne stellt das diese
partei ganz besonders gut punkten kann
bei der wählerschaft wobei man aber auch
sagen muss dass momentan die grünen auch
durchfall des future ganz stark wieder
zu ihren wurzeln zurück gedrängt werden
wenn man sich anschaut was ja eigentlich
mal ausverhandelt worden ist bei jamaika
das war ja nicht das was die
umweltbewegung mitgetragen hätte das war
ein bisschen elektro auto förderung ein
viel zu später kohleausstieg also das
ist ja eigentlich nicht das was man vor
zehn jahren als grüne politiker uhl
grüne politik bezeichnet hatte aber ich
denke die grünen haben schon gezeigt
dass eben auch eine andere form von
innerparteilicher parteistrukturen
möglich ist und auch eine gewisse
offenheit vorgelebt wird die gut bei der
wählerschaft aber auch gut bei den
mitgliedern ankommen also die grüne
jugend hat jetzt die 10.000 mitglieder
geknackt und das sind ja alles menschen
die treten nicht in der partei ein weil
sie in einem bei einem stammtisch mit
älteren herren diskutieren wollen
sondern das sind menschen die wollen
mitbestimmen und die grünen haben ja
auch als eine der ersten parteien gesagt
wir machen jetzt basisdemokratische
abstimmung von allen mitgliedern zu
unserem spitzenpersonal und dass man da
sehr früh erkannt hat dass das etwas ist
was die wähler wollen was auch die
parteibasis will das hat auch eine
gewisse glaubwürdigkeit und auch wlan
ehe gegeben die jetzt gut ankommt ist
dass ein teil oder die ganze erklärung
ich glaube es kann nur ein teil sein
aber hat also tatsächlich ging es viel
ums klima thema das haben die befragung
rund um die wahrheit gezeigt es gibt
also ein klares inhaltliches ding
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass gerade
spd und cdu seit jahren einfach veralten
das durchschnittsalter liegt jetzt bei
ungefähr 60 jahren
die menschen wieder angeht ja das was
sie mitglieder angeht und tatsächlich
glaube ich ist die lust sich in so einen
ort einzusetzen wenn da die
babyboomer-generation bisher die posten
auch gerade ist auf ortsebene unter sich
aufgeteilt hat in der kneipe relativ
begrenzt zumal bei dieser generation die
irgendwie mit social media aufgewachsen
ist ich glaub ich glaube aufgabe
historische aufgabe dieser beiden
volksparteien war es eigentlich ströme
um aufzunehmen und dann auszugleichen
also dann interessensausgleich zu finden
wenn man die jugend aber gar nicht mehr
dazu zählt zu dieser strömung dann
versagen die an dieser stelle ein
bisschen ist das tragisch fand ich die
diskussion in der spd als beschlossen
wurde man möchte jetzt zwei juso
kandidaten quasi in der europaliste
weiter nach oben setzen damit sie eine
chance auf einzug haben und darauf ist
eine große innerparteiliche debatte
ausgebrochen ob das jetzt in ordnung ist
oder nicht wo ich mir als junger wähler
denken natürlich möchte ich nicht nur
mit gemeint sein sondern ich möchte
nicht mit vertreten sind durch jemanden
der eben in meiner welt quasi liegt und
da haben die parteien einfach eine
verlängerung würde ich sagen auch eine
verweiblichung zum teil verpasst und die
grünen haben das sehr gut bewältigt muss
mein sarkozy völker fried auch einmal
sagen es nicht nur junge können junge
für politik begeistern wir hatten das
phänomen martin schulz ein mann der
alles andere als vertreter der jungen
generation war der auch wenig
weltläufigkeit und viel provinzialität
ausgestrahlt hat als er angetreten ist
als kanzlerkandidat hat es eine
wahnsinns eintrittswelle bei der spd von
jungen leuten gegeben die sich für
diesen mann begeistert haben weil er für
sie für etwas gestanden hat nämlich für
ein europa was gemeint ist was nach
vorne geht was was ein lebensgefühl
verkörpert dass du mal dazu in den
anderen punkt den ich immer machen
wollte mir ist das alles ein bisschen zu
klein klein und alles immer nur aufs
klima zu fixieren man muss doch auch mal
angucken für wen haben die beiden
volksparteien in den vergangenen jahren
in großen koalitionen die sie hatten
politik gemacht natürlich haben sie
politik für ältere gemacht weil die
älteren die mehrheit der wähler stellen
und das ist eine politik die fängt
meistens mit er nämlich mit rbi rente an
das war die mütter rente das war die
rente mit 63 das war jetzt
das gesetzlich festschreiben des
rentenniveaus es wird gerade über die
grundrente debattiert und
zukunftsgestaltung wird in diesen
parteien leider allzu oft als staatliche
altersvorsorge verstanden und wo man
noch mal angucken muss themen die
zukunft dieses landes ausmachen das sind
bildung und forschung das ist
technologischer entwicklungen ich würde
es gerne mal an einem beispiel fest
machen was ich fatale finde die ki
strategie der bundesregierung also das
was manche künstliche intelligenz wo es
eine einigkeit besteht diese entwicklung
wird alle lebensbereiche erfassen und
zum teil fundamental verändern
dafür ist will diese bundesregierung bis
2025 3 milliarden euro investieren
zum vergleich eine bedingungslose
grundrente wie die spd sie möchte würde
allein im ersten jahr 3,8 milliarden
euro in kosten und da stimmt die
relation nicht ich will nicht das eine
gegen das andere ausspielen
eine volkspartei muss aber sowohl als
auch kein ja ich glaube das ist mit
sicherheit etwas mit dem mit dem
aktuellen höhepunkt des themas
klimawandel zu tun hat dass die grünen
so stark abgeschnitten haben aber bei
wahlen spielen natürlich persönlichkeits
fragen schon auch immer eine rolle ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht dass martin
schulz damals vor allem als europäer
besonders begeistert hat sondern
irgendwie stand er war da von außen kam
für etwas anderes und sozusagen eine
hoffnung dass nach dieser etwas schwer
gewordenen ära merkel dann eben die spd
da vielleicht etwas neues beginnen
könnte es hat sich ja dann gezeigt dass
es nicht so leicht sind eine biografie
wo man sie hoch erweitert das hat auch
etwas zu stark betont aber ich glaube
man sollte auch nicht unterschätzen dass
bei den grünen heben ein neues
führungspersonal
da ist das wirklich sommer ausstrahlung
hat und wirkt und leute fasziniert und
auch begeistert manchmal auch
journalisten etwas zu sehr vielleicht
gemessen an den regeln des gewerbes aber
es ist ja unbestritten dass der ist die
grünen gelungen ist mit zwei ganz neuen
leuten diese bisschen lähmung die da
auch bei ihnen jahr statt bei seite zu
bringen also was ich damit nur sagen
will ich glaube es gibt eine mischung
auch in der faszination die jetzt gerade
die grünen aus übrigens sollte man auch
das soziale thema nicht unterschätzen an
der stelle es ist ja auch etwas was sie
relativ kontinuierlich auch immer wieder
bearbeitet haben werden die grünen die
grünen sie haben im grunde jetzt zwei
wesentliche punkte angebracht als
inhaltliches thema ich sag mal klima
gegen rente wenn man es polarisieren
will und das andere was er fried nochmal
den fokus genommen hat ist die frage wer
sind vertrauenswürdige
führungspersönlichkeiten
das hängt ja durchaus miteinander
zusammen also wenn wir die
klimaproblematik groß schwer zu
bewältigen eine große aufgabe erscheint
dann möchte ich als wählerin oder wähler
natürlich auch eine vertrauenswürdige
person die sich darum kümmert eine
person die sich gleich jetzt freuen kann
dass andrea nahles alles rampenlicht auf
sich zieht aber die alles andere als
souverän agiert hat ist die neue cdu
vorsitzende die vor der wahl etwas
hilflos einem youtube-video gegenüber
stand nach der wahl auf meinungsmache im
internet geschimpft hat hat die cdu in
gleicher weise
das führungsproblem wie die spd also ich
glaube nicht dass hkk jetzt schon so ja
so reif ist wie andrea nahles ich glaube
ich jetzt noch einigermaßen fest im fest
im sattel
insofern glaube ich das nicht stimmt
dass man vor allem ob vertrauenswürdige
führungs ja und das ist das ja auch klar
das ist ein teil der gleichung glaube
ich und dass die antwort war einfach
nicht authentisch also ich finde man
kann es sehr schön nc erzählen an diesem
gegensatz also man hat einen youtuber
der von youtube gewohnt ist ich muss
authentisch sein
zumindest erscheint er authentisch in
der art und weise wie er in seinem video
spricht und sich dafür einsetzt den
kauft man ab der sagt was er meint und
andererseits hat man dort hkk
andere cdu politiker die sich nicht
trauen ganz offensichtlich nicht trauen
ihre klimapolitik mal ein paar griffige
worte in einem video zu sprechen das war
schon jetzt hat er nur symbolkraft weil
ich glaube das war nicht die
wahlentscheidende sache aber es ist eine
schöne gegenüberstellung an der man die
hilflosigkeit der volksparteien und vor
allem auch der cdu deutlich machen kann
wenn es um junge wähler geht erst haben
sie die als spots verspottet und dann
bei file is for future hieß es immer
geht noch zur schule das sind so
scheindebatten die vielleicht auch zur
ablenkung geführt worden sind die aber
natürlich nicht gut ankommen also als
junger wähler sag ich mir doch nicht ja
okay die direktion es geht zur schule
also das ist doch unbefriedigend
ja vor allem die reaktion war einst dem
video war ja auch noch in anderer
hinsicht sehr dramatisch schlecht würde
ich sagen weil in dem man dann anfängt
über regulierung von sozialen netzwerken
zu sprechen sagt man ja nicht nur ich
höre euch nicht zu sondern man sagt ich
möchte euch gar nicht hören ja und das
finde ich extrem schwierig als
parteivorsitzende sich hinzustellen und
zu sagen okay es gibt anscheinend sehr
viele menschen die dieses thema
interessiert und anstatt über dieses
thema zu sprechen weil ich auf eine meta
diskussion aus und das also diese ganze
debatte auch um so regulierung sozialer
netzwerke regulierung von youtube zeigt
auch dass die lebensrealität einfach
eine ganz andere ist und als
jugendlicher denkt man so ok die
verstehen das einfach nicht die
verstehen das nicht warum soll ich die
wählen schöne ergänzung heute morgen
offensichtlich erwägt die cdu laut wird
am sonntag eigene youtuber aufzubauen
zumindest ein teil der cdu hat das mal
vorgeschlagen ich glaube nicht dass das
offizielle position werden wird aber das
heißt ja ja die csu ist da sogar noch
progressiver wir heute in der welt am
sonntag wissen zu berichten dass markus
söder also der bayernkurier ist in
printform eingestellt worden markus
söder möchte eine digitale offensive
starten markus söder entdeckt dass
piratenpartei potenzial in sich also ich
möchte zum beispiel
parteivorstandssitzung livestream möchte
online beteiligung und er möchte auch
einen bayerischen preis für youtuber und
influenza aus
loben also da passiert schon was markus
söder ist übrigens auch der erste
gewesen der das klima thema sehr ernst
genommen hat in bayern gab es eine
volksabstimmung zum thema bienenschutz
bienensterben seine reaktion darauf ist
eben nicht ablenken und ablehnen gewesen
sondern es gab dann einen gibt den
runden tisch naturschutz wo über
maßnahmen diskutiert und maßnahmen auch
verabschiedet werden die dieses thema
aufgreifen
also es gibt da schon eine entwicklung
und ein letzter punkt ich finde nur über
die methodik immer zu diskutieren hätte
man in einem video antworten sollen oder
ist es die pdf-datei oder ist es das
persönliche gespräch das wirklich fatale
war ja die erste reaktion der cdu als
dieses video öffentlich wurde das war
ziemlich arg der gesagt hat gebe keine
auf komplexe fragen gebe er keine
einfachen antworten und darf sei die
persönliche meinung des jähnigen der
dieses video gemacht habe und die sei
gefährlich das ist natürlich arrogant
und ignorant und aus das hat die schiene
gesetzt dass alles was danach kamen
natürlich nur noch schwer glaubwürdig
vermittelbar gewesen ist dass man diese
jungen leute ernst nehmen möchte damit
ihnen wirklich in ein gespräch kommen
nicht sie haben jetzt als drittes thema
wir hatten inhalte klima gegen rente als
symbol wir hatten das thema
persönlichkeiten sie haben das thema
stil mit eingebracht die art und weise
wie man politik macht welche mittel man
verwendet wie man im netzauftritt ich
will noch eine grafik einführen
aus dem wahlstudio die ein dilemma auf
zeigt nämlich eine karte auf der man
sehen kann wo in deutschland bei der
europawahl welche partei am stärksten
abgeschnitten hat so die roten spielen
keine grosse rolle mehr das sieht man
auf den ersten blick die grünen tupfen
sind bis auf hamburg alle relevanten
großstädte in deutschland
aber es gibt eben auch sehr viel blau
und das sind die gebiete in denen die
afg am stärksten abgeschnitten hat sie
hat zwar ihren bundestagswahl erfolg
nicht einstellen können aber
in weiten teilen brandenburgs und
sachsens wo im herbst gewählt wird ist
die afg stärkste partei herfried mike
mohring ist der fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu in thüringen der hat sinngemäß
gesagt im westen werden in der hoffnung
auf besseren klimaschutz die grünen
anstelle der union gewählt
im osten ist es die angst vor zu viel
klimaschutz die die menschen zu afd
treibt ist das dilemma richtig
beschrieben
ich kannte oder ich kann da nur ein bis
dahin nur vom lesen und muss sagen dass
seine reaktion auf dieses wahlergebnis
eine derjenigen war die mich am meisten
überzeugt hat und zwar zum einen in
dieser analyse weil sie sehr gut
beschreibt das worum es auch als
hintergrund für diese ganze frage wie
präsentiere ich mich jetzt in den
sozialen netzwerken eigentlich geht
nämlich die frage schafft es eine
volkspartei wie die cdu gegen extreme
polarisierende meinung die ich gar nicht
verurteilen sondern die vielleicht um
etwas voranzubringen auch notwendig sind
das wieder deutlich zu machen was die
aufgabe einer volkspartei ist nämlich
das was der kollege auch gesagt hat der
ausgleich der interessen und das ist ja
genau die aufgabe die sich auch in
diesem gegensatz zwischen ost und west
stellt man muss einerseits die ängste
berücksichtigen und andererseits auch
den die berechtigte forderungen beim
klimaschutz stärker voran zu gehen damit
unter einen hut bringen das ist die
eigentliche aufgabe und er hat noch ein
zweites gesagt und das führt noch mal so
ein bisschen zurück zum anfang ist es
gar nicht vertiefen aber am rand noch
sagen was was diese koalition auch
überhaupt nicht gemacht hat ist die
dinge die sie sich vorgenommen hat
einfach mal umzusetzen es wird immer
drauf gesattelt immer noch mal taktiert
immer hier noch ein prozentpünktchen
oder so ist und er hat gesagt das muss
sich jetzt ändern
und aus dieser aus der einschätzung
heraus dass die leute es leid sind wenn
nur darüber geredet wird und die dinge
die doch eigentlich schon verhandelt
sind ich meine was haben wir denn diese
endlosen koalitionsverhandlungen erlebt
wenn die nicht umgesetzt werden ich will
noch mal lassen sie mich den ersten
punkt gerne dann auch an sie frau
rosenfeld aber ich will das noch einmal
aufgreifen bei mir das eine ganz
entscheidende frage zu sein scheint
dafür ob das prinzip volkspartei das
prinzip der zukunft ist also wir haben
am klima thema zum beispiel bei der
braunkohle genau dieses beispiel ist es
aufgabe einer partei den ausgleich zu
finden den kompromiss zwischen denen die
ihre arbeit behalten wollen die
strukturveränderung verrichten und denen
die sagen braunkohle ist das
schrecklichste was man fürs klima tun
kann oder
wir hatten es beim diesel ja ähnlich auf
der einen seite sind die menschen die
ihr auto weiterfahren wollen weil es
teuer bezahlt haben auf der anderen
seite sind die schäden für die umwelt
ist es möglich dass man als partei so
etwas noch glaubwürdig ausgleicht es ist
schwer also dem verein wenn der
ausgleich immer erfolgt oder daher
ausgleich kommt nicht mehr aus dem
zentrum der parteien sondern ich habe
das gefühl es ist bei der cdu aber auch
der spd so und hinterher hecheln der
themen der anderen also vor anderthalb
jahren und ich bin froh dass es heute
nicht mehr so ist aber vor anderthalb
jahren war sozusagen die afg der
fixpunkt wie die großen parteien oder
die volksparteien reagiert haben dann
hat das alles gemessen an der afg hilft
es der afd
nun kann ich das sagen um der afg
vielleicht stimmen wegzunehmen
jetzt ist der fixpunkt da der
klimaschutz und die politik der grünen
wie viel klimaschutz machen wir kommen
wir den grünen damit zu sehr entgegen
holen wir uns vielleicht so wähler
zurück und wie schwer so ein ausgleich
ist zeigt der kohlekompromiss der
gefunden worden ist 2038 rauszugehen aus
der kohle und mit 40 milliarden euro
insgesamt den strukturwandel zu
begleiten
und man muss auch sagen dieses land hat
sich eine sehr besondere aufgabe
gestellt wir steigen gleichzeitig aus
kern- und kohle
die aus und das ist noch mal ein ganz
besonderer kraftakt und alle mitzunehmen
erfordert kompromisse und kompromisse
sind habe ich das gefühl in diesen
zeiten nicht sonderlich gefragt sondern
wer kompromisse eingeht ist oft ein
verlierer oder zu schwach oder es wird
das nächste extrem von von der anderen
seite gefordert
renault gut funktioniert das kann eine
partei heute noch diese gegensätzlichen
positionen ausgleichen dieses aufgabe
eine volkspartei wenn der die cdu noch
so nennen wollen ja grundsätzlich ist es
natürlich immer eine aufgabe einer
partei oder vor allem auch einer
regierung die aus zwei parteien besteht
kompromisse zu finden das muss man
natürlich tun
trotz einem glaube ich schon dass die
wahl über die umfrageergebnisse auch
gezeigt haben das ist nicht unbedingt
für den wahlerfolg entscheidend sein
muss oder sein darf er sich nur an der
afg zu orientieren weil viele menschen
dann eben sagen ich wähle trotzdem das
original
wichtiger wäre es wird die einzelnen
parteien da wirklich ein eigenes profil
eigenes profil zu entwickeln und selbst
klar zu machen was ist mein unique
selling point quasi weshalb wie sollen
sie mich wählen und bei den grünen ist
dass der klimaschutz bei der ard ist es
eben ein thema was ich persönlich sehr
schwierig finde und bei den
sozialdemokraten das zeigen auch
umfragen fallen fragen sich viele
menschen warum soll ich euch eigentlich
wählen ja und vor allem muss man ja auch
bedenken dass viele also dass eine
stärke einer partei natürlich auch eine
sogwirkung entfalten kann wenn man das
gefühl hat man ist auf einer
gewinnerseite ja dann kann man auch noch
mal einen gewissen bonus abgreifen in
der wählerschaft
ich denke dieser bonus ist für die
volksparteien jetzt vorbei ja und dann
müssen sie sich eben inhaltlich stärker
aufstellen und sagen was ist meine
vision für deutschland im jahr 2030 ja
aber ich gebe die frage noch mal weiter
also die grünen radikal für klimaschutz
wahnsinnig attraktiv die afg radikal
gegen migration war zu zeiten der
flüchtlingswelle wahnsinnig attraktiv
und dazwischen parteien die hilflos
zuschauen
das war zumindest wahnsinnig attraktiv
für eine gewisse minderheit in der
bevölkerung bei der optik ich glaube ist
es immer noch aufgabe der cdu interessen
auszugleichen und die müssen natürlich
auch kompetenz demonstrieren wenn man
sich jahrelang nicht so richtig um das
thema klimawandel kümmert und gar keine
köpfe hat die das
noch vertreten dann kann man zwar immer
noch erzählen wir gleichen interessen
aus und nicht so schnell aber wenn
unterm strich bleibt wir haben uns ziele
gesetzt wie erfüllen sie nicht dann ist
es erstmal kein kein gutes argument wenn
man erzählen würde wir erfüllen unsere
klimaziele und zwar auf die art und
weise die auch menschen nicht abhängt
beziehungsweise interessenausgleich dann
wäre das ein besseres argument
und ich glaube das zeigen auch umfragen
eine grosse mehrheit der deutschen
findet nicht dass die groko bei dem
thema klimawandel kompetent ist und
genug getan hat und erst mal erst mal
irgendwas tun aus dem nup aus dem pott
kommen ich glaube das wäre schon mal ein
erster erster hinweis wo es hingehen
könnte was ich besonders interessant
fand beim deutschlandtrend hat sich
gezeigt dass also bei der frage welcher
partei trauen sie die meiste kompetenz
im bereich klimaschutz so waren
natürlich die grünen auf platz zwei auf
platz eins und auf platz zwei war aber
die union ja nicht die linke nicht die
grünen nicht die spd sondern wirklich
die union
und da müssen sich die anderen parteien
einfach fragen woran liegt das und ich
finde es sehr tragisch gerade bei der
spd mit dem erneuerbaren energien gesetz
ja hat man ja eigentlich die die wende
in deutschland damals eingeleitet ja
aber weil man eben danach nicht diesen
kurs konsequent weitergegangen ist den
man unter rot-grün angefangen hat rechts
ich das jetzt einfach auch also ich find
den aspekt spannend sie sagen wer
vermitteln will wer kompromisse aufbauen
will muss zunächst mal kompetenz auf dem
entsprechenden politikfeld haben wir
sind kurz vor dem ende der sendung an
dem tag an dem die spd parteivorsitzende
wie andere vor ihr alles hingeworfen hat
lassen sie uns da zum schluss noch
nachdenken spekulieren wer kann wer
sollte wer wird diese partei künftig
führen
ich bin da ganz ehrlich ratlos ich
glaube also natürlich wird frau dreyer
das jetzt erstmal kommissarisch machen
vielleicht sogar länger aber
möglicherweise muss die spd auch mal
grundsätzlich überlegen welche form der
führungsstruktur sie sich eigentlich
geben will das wird der
fraktion schon diskutiert dass man
vielleicht auch mit einer doppelspitze
arbeitet dass man jemanden wie matthias
miersch der ein sehr starker
umweltpolitiker ist aber vielleicht in
anderen fragen nicht so firmen ist noch
jemand zweites zur seite stellt und
damit auch einen gewissen politischen
ausgleich schafft so was ist ja alles
denkbar insofern ist glaube ich die idee
jetzt sich ein bisschen zeit zu lassen
nicht verkehrt anderes als dieses land
muss auch regiert werden und die spd ist
ja die sich auch sehr viel noch
vorgenommen hat für dieses jahr
wenn ich an die grundrente denke oder an
das klimaschutzgesetz die das auch
durchsetzen wollen und wenn man sich
jetzt allzu lange nur mit sich selbst
beschäftigt wird das natürlich nicht
vorangehen einen kurzen satz kann ich
ihnen noch geben es sei denn sie mögen
passen weil sie olaf scholz wird
jedenfalls nicht die lösung sein das ist
der mann der regelmäßig bei
parteivorstands waren die schlechtesten
ergebnisse einfährt und ich glaube nicht
dass er der richtige ist um eine so
zerstrittene partei wieder
zusammenführen zu können bedarf nicht
sehr herzlich für diese runde ich glaube
wir haben vor allem deutlich gemacht was
gerade in bewegung ist die suche nach
halt ist die notwendige suche der
parteien
die hat mit inhaltliche orientierung
aber auch viel damit zu tun wer die
generation ist die jetzt zum beispiel
cdu und spd führen und bedanke mich sehr
herzlich
wir halten sie in der ard natürlich war
die weiteren entwicklungen auf dem
laufenden
jetzt erst mal das europamagazin und bei
phoenix und im radio presseclub
nachgefragt danke tschüss und lassen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im fernsehen bei phoenix im
radio bei wdr 5 jetzt haben sie das wort
und das hat zunächst christine neukamm
aus ja bekommen frau kam in der sendung
sind dran
ich hoffe die frau rosie sizer wie sehr
gut gefallen
weiter gehört also mit diesen vorwurf
muss ich mal angeschrieben worden ist
die projekte dies wurde noch lauter
baustellen von geschichten wurden von
cook aber die ware geht richtig
behandeln sind und wirtschaft ich bin
jetzt für die dem volk
ich hoffe die frühere leiterin der
holmes quasi nicht antreten da gibt 1,8
millionen betroffene design also quasi
liegt erforscht worden und diese
besserstellung und abstriche von der
rettung vor der grund hat er nochmal an
bewertungsfragen dollar rente also der
gegenrichtung schlechter gestellt
ja also ich habe verstanden das ist
nicht ganz unser thema heute aber ich
verstehe sie so dass sie sagen
für sie ist das am ende schon wichtig
und entscheidend was da für sie getan
wird richtig gemacht
politik machen ich bedanke mich für ihre
meinung von neukamm grüße in die
oberpfalz und wir gehen weiter nach
schwäbisch allzu gern ratsherr braatz
guten tag haben sie ein argument oder
eine frage für uns ich habe eine frage
und ein gruß an die und mich
unerklärlich wie eine partei die an drei
in drei bundesländern aus der regierung
gefallen
wenn ich in schleswig holstein ist ihre
regierung gescheitert in nordrhein
westfalen und in niedersachsen und jetzt
auf einmal so ein höhepunkt von den
grünen die nur mit einem thema buchen
deswegen wirklich immer raten sie schon
mal fakten schaffen
in den bundesländern oder uns bürgern
sagen
ab nächste woche und 13 monat weise wird
der strom zurückgefahren weil wir
bekommen hier noch 61 prozent von den
kohlekraftwerken noch ein teil aus
atomkraft also fakten schaffen wir
wollen vieles machen eine frage an alle
teilnehmer darunter japan beziehen sie
sich auf die grünen oder ok ja das war
mir nicht deutlich geworden also ihre
frage ist wie die grünen fakten schaffen
wollen
okay wer traut sich da eine antwort zu
es ist wahrscheinlich nicht an uns jetzt
für die grünen hier zu sagen wie sie
fakten schaffen wollen aber ich glaube
das problem was der zuschauer beschreibt
ist ja auch in den letzten tagen die man
mal wieder angesprochen worden natürlich
sind die grünen auch eine partei die
jetzt seit vielen jahren gerade in der
bundespolitik nicht mehr in der
regierung waren es ihm nicht vorzuwerfen
aber es ist natürlich auch die
möglichkeit dass sich programmatisch
sehr weit aus dem fenster zu hängen wenn
man das nicht umsetzen muss wenn wir
dagegen aber schauen was grüne
regierungen in den ländern insbesondere
in hessen stichwort flughafenausbau oder
in baden württemberg wo der herr
kretschmann sich mit der autoindustrie
also schlecht nun nicht versteht
wirklich machen wenn sie an der
regierung sind dann gibt es da eine
diskrepanz das ist glaube ich
offensichtlich und deswegen wäre es
natürlich interessant zu sehen wie die
grünen den anspruch den sie jetzt haben
dass alles schneller und effektiver zu
machen dann auch umsetzen würden
danke wir gehen weiter nach hinten zu
marcel mandela guten tag guten tag gegen
die runde bekommen sie sind dran
also ich habe erst mal eine herzige
medienkritik weil ich denke dass die
medien mittlerweile eine art kaisertreue
guten regierung vertrauen entwickelt
haben weil es wird immer von einem
politischen erdbeben oder ein
bienensterben der volksparteien
berichtet anstatt sich mal überlegen das
ist in der demokratie auch alternativen
gibt und die volksparteien die cdu und
spd nicht alternativlos sind weil auch
bei annegret kramp karrenbauer die
meisten sie jetzt sagt dass man die
medien regulieren müsste wenn wir nicht
mehr regieren passiert etwas ganz
schlimmes
das wird einfach ein bild ab als er ist
auch dass er keine angst hat gegen ihn
gebe wenn wir dann also wenn meine
generation ich bin 30 land ihre dass die
ist nicht mal gebacken bekommen
das ferkel mit betäubung kastriert
werden dass wir viel ganz kleines thema
wo man sich dann auf hält was man nicht
lösen kann und dann andere kleines
themen die man nicht lösen kann dann
wird mit denen die industrialisierung
oder einen krieg gegen das automobil
gesprochen anstatt einfach mal gucken
wie man in die zukunft blickt die
generation kräftig auf das autonome
fahren freut sich auch die
flugaktivitäten 30 40 jahren sowieso
geben wird und wir halten uns immer noch
in der cdu auch wie sich an einem
youtube-video euro frei herr bande la
danke ich spitze es noch mal zu
er hat gesagt er hat vor allem medien
kritik weil er den eindruck hat die
medien würden den regierenden noch
regierenden parteien vor allem die treue
halten wollen und könnten sich keine
alternative vorstellen
wir schreiben also wir medien ich fühle
mich jetzt angesprochen klassische
medien
wir beschreiben phänomene wir
analysieren für domäne wir kommentieren
auch phänomene
wir sind aber nicht teil der regierung
sondern beobachter dieser regierung und
auch die phänomene die er genannt hat
greta thunberg ist natürlich präsent in
allen medien
sie wird interviewt sie wird
wahrgenommen es gibt auch kritische
stimmen zu ihr ferkelkastration küken
schreddern das taucht doch alles oder
das ist alles sind themen die wir nicht
ignorieren über die wir berichten die
wir problematisieren und deswegen kann
ich diese medienkritik nicht annehmen ja
wobei also ich fand die diskussion in
den medien oder bzw die
berichterstattung über file is for
future vor allem zu beginn unterirdisch
muss ich sagen also es wurde dann sehr
oft die debatte um das schuleschwänzen
aufgegriffen klar die kam auch teilweise
aus dem bundestag
aber er denke ich wäre es dann auch
aufgabe von journalisten sich nicht an
solchen meter debatten aufzuhängen
sondern wirklich in der sache zu fragen
was ist denn ihre position so
klimapolitik wie wollen sie riskiert
beispielsweise im fall der grünen ganz
konkret jetzt für die nächsten jahre
lösen also ganz klar konzepte
vorzubringen und stattdessen haben wir
jetzt auch bei dem youtube-video wieder
die debatte ob es in ordnung ist das
prominente quasi sich öffentlich zu
einer partei positionieren und was das
denn jetzt für die medienlandschaft
bedeutet also da habe ich das gefühl
dass auch die presse so ein bisschen um
sich selbst kreist was mich als leser
dann in erster linie erstmal sekundär
interessiert und interessant fange ich
an dieser debatte auch ein bisschen
tragisch auch das hier ist ja jahrelang
vollkommen selbstverständlich fanden das
prominente sagen wählt diese partei
wählt diese parteien nicht ja also wenn
günther craß sich hingesetzt hat und
gesagt aber selbst nicht erlebt
überzeugter sozialdemokrat wählen sie
diese partei davon dass alle toll und
eine bereicherung für die demokratie und
wenn die junge generation auch ohne
aufforderung einer partei übrigens von
sich aus zu dem ergebnis kommt wir
machen jetzt eine wahlempfehlung weil
das natürlich auch eine mobilisierende
wirkung für die wahlbeteiligung
insgesamt hat dann diskutieren wir
erstmal über meter debatten also darf
ich sagen da muss man sich diese diesen
schuh auch anziehen und diese kritik
annehmen daher beim dealer waren sind
noch mal ja ich wollte noch mal sagen
medien gemeint sondern als die regierung
dass man sich bei solchen plan nicht mal
ein werden kann und wie sagen
generation problem klimawandel lösen
wenn man noch nicht mal beim
roboterbauer herbei
ich versuche auch meine persönliche
antwort weil ich durchaus ihre
wahrnehmung verstehen kann also mein
blick darauf ist dass wir in der
bundesrepublik mit union und spd
jahrzehntelang zwei parteien hatten die
alternativen waren wir hatten früher
wahlkämpfe wo entweder die eine oder die
andere große partei sich anschließenden
koalitionspartner gesucht hat und durch
das schrumpfen
hat man gerade das gefühl da fehlen die
alternativen die so stark wären eine
regierung bilden zu können also
vielleicht haben wir das gleiche
empfinden nur eine andere perspektive
drauf da kann natürlich sind halt dieser
tunnel liegt auch billigen rp halt was
anderes haben sie völlig recht bedanke
mich danke für die offene kritik und wir
gehen nach braunschweig zu ingelore
guten tag guten tag ich wollte einen
gedanken die debatte schweifen
ob das nicht das problem der großen
koalition vielleicht auch an personen in
der großen koalition festgemacht werden
kann wenn man sich zum beispiel einen
herrn seehofer anschaut völlig
parteiunabhängig wie ungeschickt er die
ganze zeit an ihr trainiert hat und
agieren wird dann muss man doch
verstehen dass gerade die junge
generation sich von der politik und von
den klassischen parteien abwendet ok ja
klar abdanken möchte dass jemand
kommentieren müssen sich also mein
eindruck ist dass die fliehkräfte in
dieser großen koalition von beginn an
sehr groß waren und dass zudem verhalten
der personen geführt hat also dass es
zwischen csu und cdu einen streit
gegeben hat dass die spd versucht hatten
sich auf kosten des koalitionspartners
zu profilieren und dadurch ist ein
streit entstanden der das resultat sehen
wir jetzt dass auch vielleicht das
verhalten von horst seehofer kann man so
erklären wobei ich schon sagen würde
dass horst seehofer teil dieser
fliehkräfte war denn in dem er gerade
die themen der afd immer wieder stark
gemacht hat stark in den vordergrund
gedrückt hat
den debatten begonnen hat die um diese
themen kreisen haben wir es eben
verpasst um andere themen zu reagieren
vielleicht auch zu wandern debatte
geführt hätten
wir wollen nicht weiter wir herrn
seehofer sprechen frage meinte ihnen
glaube ich als beispiel für eine
entwicklung
wir gehen weiter ans deutsche eck das
passt doch jetzt oder wolfgang von
nathusius aus koblenz guten tag ich habe
bemerkung oder bis heute frage zu was
frau rosenfeld gesagt hatte über die
volksparteien dass wir eine große
aufgabe es ist interessenausgleich zu
machen und die alten volksparteien der
bonner republik etwa die machtinteressen
ausgleiche in bereichen die zwar sehr
unterschiedliche positionen waren aber
kompromissfähig bisschen mehr
gesamtschule oder elite arbeitnehmer
weniger und so weiter das motto man ja
irgendwie abstufen und kompromisse
finden und meine frage jetzt tritt das
also gerade am beispiel klimapolitik
überhaupt noch zu wenn wir auch das
hätte mike mohring dabei eine will wohl
auch so ausgedrückt eigentlich waren auf
der einen seite eine alternative hat die
kompromiss fish ist wenn das was uns die
klimaforscher als passten da vorgehen
dann ist das nicht verhandelbar
also man kann da eigentlich keine
komponistin und dazu das ist also gerade
kein thema für die volksparteien ist das
gericht darin nicht schlafen oder oder
genießen können dass er ja das ist wird
gerne das ist eine spannende frage sie
zielt nämlich in den kern dessen worum
es gerade geht also dass der klimawandel
ein handeln erfordert ist ja
unbestritten das haben auch hat diese
regierung akzeptiert angenommen und
versucht es auch umzusetzen
und wie dann die ausgestaltung der
erreichung der klimaziele vonstatten
geht das ist ja die große
herausforderung dass es eben nicht
abgehängte gibt dass es nicht die sozial
schwachen am stärksten am ende trifft
wie gestalte ich eine co2 steuer so dass
sie eine lenkungswirkung hat und nicht
dafür gedacht ist dass der staat noch
mehr geld an ihre verdient was es mit
strukturwandel mit arbeitsplätzen die
verloren gehen
das ist die aufgabe der regierungs und
volksparteien dort einen weg und
ausgleich zu finden ehrfried laufen wir
gefahr dass das thema klima die
gesellschaft radikalisiert weil eine
seite sagt da kann man keinen kompromiss
eingehen
na ja das wird davon abhängen wie die
politik in den nächsten in der nächsten
zeit damit umgeht klar ich glaube schon
dass es im moment eine sehr starke
sympathie für diese fälle ist for future
bewegung gibt und zwar nicht nur
innerhalb der b jugend weiß ich bis 25
30 jährigen sondern auch der
elterngeneration
das ist ja auch ein effekt der eigenen
erziehung bei vielen leuten dass sie
jetzt sehen dass doch nicht alles
vergeblich waren sich ihre kinder dann
doch für politische themen interessieren
von denen manches vielleicht schon
aufgegeben hatten
radikalisierung der punkt dass das nicht
verhandelbar ist wenn die wenn die
vorgaben der wissenschaft stimmen das
ist ja unbestreitbar
und trotzdem wird glaube ich in diesem
system in dem wir leben in einem
demokratischen system wo man auch
mehrheiten braucht und ausgleich
schaffen muss es nicht anders gehen als
überein wenn sie so wollen zivilisierten
weg der entscheidungsfindung dazu
lösungen zu kommen ob die dann
ausreichend das weiß ich nicht aber es
gibt keinen anderen vernünftigen weg
dahin
danke nach koblenz herr von nathusius
und machen wir ein stück weiter
rheinabwärts stationen in wesseling bei
rigobert pilot guten tag
einen schönen guten tag in die runde ich
mache es kurz fortgeschrittene zeit es
geht um die partei jetzt richtig aber
viel eher interessiert mich das thema
inwieweit muss sich die spd heute die
muss die frage beantworten will sie mehr
nach recht falsche ausdruck wird ihm ja
sozial werden und konservativ werden wie
es früher in westdeutschland im
ruhrgebiet war
oder will sie die linken überholen oder
gar noch grüner werden als die grünen
ja ich glaube dass diese kriterien
schwer anwendbar sind weil das was das
ruhrgebiet früher war
das gibt es ebenso heute nicht mehr
sondern es gibt andere herausforderungen
die den begegnet werden muss übrigens
auch gerade was die jüngere generation
angeht diese ja nicht nur sorgen macht
um den klimawandel sondern auch was
berufsausbildung fortkommen und solche
dinge angeht darauf wird man ja
antworten finden müssen ob das jetzt
irgendwie links oder rechts ist dass ich
glaube diese kriterien sind heute
einfach nicht mehr so gültig wie sie
lange zeit waren als das parteiensystem
natürlich auch noch viel leichter und
überschaubar war wird sicherlich teil
der debatte in der spd seien die wir
jetzt den nächsten wochen beobachten
bedanke mich herzlich nochmal einen
wunderschönen sonntag als köllges
[Musik]